when it comes to overseas travel in a
global pandemic
the unpredictability is enough to put
anyone off
but now the government's promising
clarity no watch lists
just a simple green amber red system
leaving no doubt of who can go where
and what the consequences will be
[Music]
but for tour operators like fiona
charrington
this summer is pretty much a write-off
we need to know that the decisions taken
now
stay in place to give people the
confidence to book and to know that
they're not worrying from the moment
they do book
that the holiday is going to be taken
away from them at the last minute or
while they're away
an updated travel list is expected
imminently
with france likely to go back to the
straightforward amber list
with travellers no longer needing to
quarantine on return
but for stuart bradley who runs a
campsite in the loire valley
it's been a disaster there's so much
indecision around
people are now booking or have booked
back in the uk
so they're not going to take at this
stage in
the summer holidays where we've
literally got three to four weeks left
before the children go back to school in
the uk
they're probably not going to take a
punch on coming over to france
everyone heading back to the uk needs to
do a pre-travel
test and fill in a passenger locator
form but further testing
and quarantine requirements depends on
where you've been
in 2019 before kovic changed everything
18 million people from the uk headed to
spain
and 10 million to france hardly
surprising that every announcement
is so eagerly awaited the prime minister
says he understands what's at stake
i know how important holidays are to
people people think about them they save
up for them
people yearn to go abroad this year
totally i totally get that we've got to
balance that
against the need to protect our country
against the influx of
of new variants with costly testing
form filling and constant speculation
about lists
braving any overseas trip takes some
determination
but at least travellers should soon have
a clearer idea
whether their summer holiday has a hope
of going ahead
emma birchley sky news